bonjour ceci est un nouveau format comme
vous pouvez le constater que je vais
vous présenter dès maintenant je ne sais
pas si vous l'aviez remarqué mais il ya
des filles sur internet et même sur
youtube même qu on fait plein de vidéos
et qu'on adore ça du coup on est
tellement nombreuses qu'on a décidé de
se rassembler et de créer entre autres
des mois thématique durant lesquelles on
sort chacune une vidéo sur un thème
dans la limite de notre inspiration et
de notre motivation bien sûr vous
retrouverez toutes les vidéos de mes
partenaires inkling dans la description
alors allé les voir et le premier thème
choisi est le rose
je trouve ce thème pas mal parce qu'on
peut l'aborder selon plein d'angles
différents scientifiques chimiques
sociologiques historiques et bien sûr
deviné qu'elle approche des choisi d'un
point de vue personnel par contre je
n'aime pas le rose j'ai rejeté cette
couleur très tôt au même titre que les
petits dauphins argenté et j'emporte
presque jamais mais cette couleur a une
histoire passionnante et nous allons la
découvrir ensemble donc on va faire de
l'histoire des couleurs et avant de
détailler sur le rose on va faire une
petite présentation des couleurs au
moyen-âge la vision qu'on a aujourd'hui
des couleurs que vous voyez nos ancêtres
et fossés pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
en raison de l'état de conservation de
certaines oeuvres tentures vêtements
construction qu'on peut observer
aujourd'hui les couleurs ont pu passer
se délaver perdre leur éclat et donc on
a du mal à s'imaginer des couleurs vives
y a qu'à voir les statuts et les
peintures dans les églises c'est grise
et terne et ça court le risque d'être
restaurée avec les pieds méfiance donc
ensuite avant la diffusion de
l'électricité et les couleurs
n'apparaissait pas de la même manière
que maintenant quand on s'éclairait à la
chandelle à bouger ou la lampe à huile
ça ne produisait pas le même effet
qu'avec un néo ou même une simple
ampoule de nos jours la perception des
couleurs au xiiie siècle et de nos jours
connaît donc de grandes différences et
pas seulement à la nuit tombée comment
était défini les couleurs au moyen de
nombreux auteurs ont disserté sur les
arcs en ciel en tentant de déterminer de
quelle couleur il était composé leurs
travaux nous renseigne sur ce qui était
considéré comme une couleur à l'époque
certains décrivent les arcs en ciel
comme composé de trois quatre ou cinq
couleurs et roger bacon ans décrit
carrément si bleu vert rouge gris rose
et blanc à l'époque on parle pas encore
de spectre des couleurs et tout ça on
retrouve également les couleurs dans les
armoiries qui sont inventés à partir du
12ème siècle les couleurs des blasons
qui sont surtout utiles lors des
tournois pour différencier les candidats
sont au nombre de six
blanc jaune rouge bleu noir et vert et
elles sont désignés dans la langue du
blason argent or gueule azur sable et
sinope c'est quand même plus classe
on remarquera que ces couleurs sont les
six couleurs de base on ne parle pas
encore de couleurs primaires
mais ce sont les seules couleurs qui
n'ont pas de référent dans la nature
elles sont abstraites contrairement à l'
orange qui est tiré de ceux ci aux roses
qui vient de là ou encore du marron qui
vient de cet objet
michel pastoureau qui a beaucoup
travaillé sur l'histoire des couleurs
les qualifie de deux mille couleurs
les couleurs sont aussi utilisés pour
les teintures des vêtements et pas
seulement
tous les vêtements sont un an moyen-âge
pas uniquement ceux des riches mais
aussi ceux des plus pauvres
les vêtements des riches ont cependant
des couleurs plus vives en raison de la
meilleure qualité des tissus et des
teintures utilisé mais il n'existe pas
de couloirs réservés aux riches et de
couleur réservée aux pauvres dans les
cours princières on ne tient pas
uniquement les vêtements mais aussi un
peu tout ce qui passe par la main comme
les aliments ou les plages des plumages
des animaux comme quoi atteindre son
caniche en rose ne date pas d'hier pour
désigner les couleurs qui ne sont pas
les couleurs de base ou bien pour
apporter des nuances on se réfère
souvent les éléments naturels
on trouve dans les archives des bleus
nuage safran rouge grenade couleurs de
plomb couleurs de cristal de bombay où
comme le coup d'une colombe pour faire
référence à une couleur et riz descente
tout ça fait un peu penser à pau d'année
à ses robes couleur de lune maintenant
on va s'intéresser aux roses comme vous
l'aurez peut-être compris le rose n'est
pas l'une des couleurs de base et il
n'est même pas considéré comme une
couleur avant un moment même au 19e
siècle les théoriciens la couleur refuse
de lui donner le statut de véritable
couleur pour eux ce n'est qu'un mélange
de rouge et de blanc synthétique est un
peu vulgaire par mois qui est son nom
vient de la fleur éponyme c'est pourquoi
on parle d'abord de couleurs de rose
avant d'employer le terme rose tout
simplement vers la fin du moyen-âge
on l'appelle aussi parfois rouge clair
au rouge blanc en fait au moyen âge
n'est considéré que comme une nuance du
rouge et même assez peu apprécié parce
qu'on a du mal à en fabriquer une belle
teinte le rose est aussi appelée incarna
au moyen-âge
et c'est sous ce nom qu'on le retrouve
souvent dans les recettes de teinturerie
par exemple le rose est ainsi obtenu par
peinture grâce à différents procédés on
obtient du rosa à partir de kermesse de
l'unc arnaque de la couleur fleurs de
pêcher à partir de garance et de la
couleur de rose sèche à la garance et
hautbois de brésil la teinture aubade
brésil et celle qui est privilégiée à
partir de la fin du moyen âge
il s'agit d'un bois importé de sumatra
et qui coûte assez cher donc c'est
pourquoi le rose est assez peu diffusée
à partir du xvième siècle on découvre un
bois très voisins en amérique du sud et
qui est moins cher
c'est grâce à sakho 16e 17e siècle rose
est enfin diffusé
c'est aussi grâce à la découverte d'un
bois proche du web brésil au brésil que
le brésil s'appelle brésil vous suivez
l' usage du terme rose se diffuse au
xviie siècle quand cette couleur devient
plus fréquentes dans les vêtements et
dans l'art il existe des tas de nuances
de rose que je vais vous citer parce
qu'elles ont le joli nom d rose clair
peuvent s'appeler bis carnation carnet
cher coquille d'oeuf cuisse de nymphe
pêche rose dragée ou vieux rose pour les
rose foncé on a le capucine cuisse de
nymphe ému en rose fuchsia grenadine
héliotrope nacarat pelures d'oignon
rouge ballets roses bonbon rose thé rose
vif fraises fraise écrasée framboise lui
la somme on le rose est souvent
considérée comme une couleur féminine
parce qu'en france au moins depuis le
16e siècle rouge est considérée comme
une couleur féminine jusqu'au 19ème
siècle les mariés porter des robes
rouges
auparavant il est intéressant de noter
que c'était tout l'inversé aujourd'hui
le rouge était une couleur 200 associés
aux dieux mars de la guerre donc une
couleur d'hommes plein de testostérone
alors que le bleu était la couleur de la
vierge marie qu'on peut pas faire plus
féminin jusqu'au 16e siècle c'est donc
le bleu qui est une couleur féminine est
pas le rouge dit l'heureuse au fil du
temps le rose devient donc une couleur
associée aux femmes mais aussi à
l'enfance au bonheur romantisme et même
à l'érotisme avec le téléphone rose par
exemple voilà pour moi j'espère que
cette petite vidéo vous a plu j'ai
choisi de faire un historique du rose ce
qui n'est pas évident parce qu'il ya
très peu de travaux sur le sujet le
grand historien de la couleur et michel
pastoureau que j'ai déjà cité et il a
travaillé sur le noir le bleu
le rouge le vert mais pas le rose
évidemment ici l'histoire des couleurs
vous intéresse ces travaux sont vraiment
très intéressant et agréable à dire ges
maintenant la parole aux autres filles
dont vous retrouverez le vidéo dans la
description à mesure qu'elles sortiront
et de toute manière je le partagerai
également sur les réseaux sociaux
j'espère que vous avez aimé notre idée
que vous serez toujours là pour le thème
de la prochaine vidéo sera du chronique
de profs promis et donc je vous dis à
bientôt